FEMALE SPEAKER: At Google,
we're surrounded by technology,
but we may rarely think
about the first pain
years and the struggles
that they faced to get us
to where we are today.
The word brilliant
is frequently used
to describe Alan Turing, who
was not only one of the earliest
computer scientists, but also
a mathematician, logician,
biologist, and encrypt
analyst famous for breaking
the German Enigma encryption
during World War II
and saving millions of lives.
His story has inspired films,
literature, and even music,
and I'm honored today
to introduce his nephew
and biographer.
So please join me in giving
a warm welcome to Sir Dermot
Turing.
[APPLAUSE]
SIR DERMOT TURING: So thank
you for having me today.
It's a pleasure to be here.
I thought what might
be of interest to you
to pick out some of the details
of Alan Turing's life, which
are perhaps some of the
lesson known aspects,
but I'd thought I'd
focus on machinery.
I'm not going to go into
the intricacies of coding
of the first British
computers, but I
thought you might like to
see some of the hardware,
if you like, that
Alan Turing worked on.
And there's some really quite
interesting aspects of this,
because it starts off really
quite early in his life,
perhaps earlier than
you might have expected.
I'm sure you're all familiar
with this horrible thing, which
is the paper that he wrote in
1936 on computable numbers,
and I expect you could actually
explain to me what it means,
so I'm not going to
try and patronize
you buy giving you any
sense of it, but of course
the key point here is, if you
take yourself back to 1936.
They haven't actually
got machinery
that was capable of doing
more than one thing,
and that's very hard for
us from our viewpoint
to grasp that idea,
but the easiest way
I think to think
of it is when you
go to your kitchen your
kitchen equipment is only
capable of doing one thing.
So your kettle, for example, is
a kettle full of boiling water,
but it is not very useful
for frying eggs in.
A frying pan is great
for frying eggs in,
but it's pretty useless
for the making frothing up
egg whites to make a
meringue, for example.
Each piece of equipment
has one function,
and that was the
same with essentially
computing equipment,
calculating machinery
that was in place around
the prewar period.
So the idea that
Alan Turing came up
with in trying to solve
this mathematical problem,
the Entscheidungsproblem, the
idea of a multi purpose machine
that could change its
functionality by being fed
a different set
of instructions--
essentially what we call these
days a program-- that was just
a really radical
breakthrough, but of course,
everybody-- nobody
though of this as other
than just essentially a
mathematical device, a theory
to enable people
to get to the heart
of the Entscheidungsproblem, but
you might well then ask, well,
where did this idea of a machine
to solve mathematical problems
actually come from?
The answer to this
is quite interesting,
because it probably comes
from the guy whose picture is
on the left hand
side of this slide,
a professor at
Cambridge University
called Max Newman,
who was giving
the talks, the lectures on
mathematical problems including
the Entscheidungsproblem,
and he'd
described the
Entscheidungsproblem
in terms of is there a
mechanical process which
could be applied to any given
theorem to know whether or not
it was provable?
And so it's this phrase,
the mechanical process,
that I think started
Alan Turing's though
processes running to see if
there was a way of tackling
the Entscheidungsproblem,
and hence
this sort of
theoretical blueprint
for a universal
computing machine.
But he doesn't just leave it at
this theoretical mathematical
stage.
Actually, he's quite a
hands on sort of guy,
and so actually what he wants
to do is start thinking about
what would those instruction
tables, essentially
the programs, look like?
And this becomes
quite interesting,
because this is
also roughly 1936,
and he's explaining
to this lady,
and this lady is the
mother of this school days
friend Christopher Morcom.
He's still in touch with
her for about 10 years
after leaving school, about
10 years after Christopher
Morcom's died.
Any of you seen "The
Imitation Game,"
you know about this-- it's
slightly mythical, actually--
this story about this strong
childhood friendship he
had with Christopher Morcom.
In fact, they only knew each
other for about 15 months.
Alan was much more interested
in Christopher's mother.
It was this lady, and
he's explaining to her
in the mid 1930s,
the rules of Go.
You know the Japanese
game you play
with black and white counters.
Yeah, there's lots
of people nodding.
So what he's doing
is he's actually
writing algorithmic
processes down
to explain to her
how to play Go,
and this is quite interesting
because he's actually not
only thinking about the theory
of a universal computing
machine.
He's thinking about how you
actually write programs,
and he's also thinking at
the same time about how
you go about building machines.
Now, this thing-- he started
building this machine
in about 1937,
'38, and what he's
trying to do-- there's some
mathematicians amongst you--
the Riemann zeta function
might-- oh yes, we're
getting one or two
nods, so that's good.
Don't ask me.
I have no idea what it is.
Anyway, it's something
to do with prime numbers
and how spaced out they are.
No, I don't mean spaced out.
That could mean
something involving
the use of inappropriate
substances,
but they're not evenly
distributed, are they?
Along those sort
of numerical axis.
So this Riemann
zeta function helps
you understand how they're
spaced out so I understand.
So he wanted to build
an analog machine that
would help find the solutions
to the zeta function,
and this involved
apparently cutting
gear teeth, each of which would
have a prime number of spokes
around it.
It's a prime number of
teeth around the wheel,
and you put these
gear wheels together,
and then you crank
a handle, and it
would spit out the solutions.
So this blueprint, which was
not drawn by Alan Turing,
but it's of his
machine-- it's actually
in the archive at King's
College, Cambridge,
and apparently he started
making these wheels out
of brass, these gear wheels.
And if you've visited his
rooms at King's College,
Cambridge just before
the Second World War,
you would probably
have tripped over them.
They were scattered all over the
floor and all over the table,
and unfortunately
World War II broke out
and prevented essentially the
machine ever being assembled.
So we'll never know
whether it worked, and it
would be very nice to know one
day if somebody could actually
use this blueprint try and
put the thing together.
Anyway, so he's
not only thinking
about the theory of
machinery, and he's
thinking about the
possibilities for programming,
but he's also very
interested in a hands
on sense in the hardware.
And that probably makes
him an ideal candidate
to be hired to join the code
breaking team of Bletchley
Park, because as you all
know, the key problem in 1939
was that the Germans were using
the Enigma machine to encipher
their communications, and with
the vast number of permutations
as the way the
machine can be set up
there is a serious challenge.
You can't use one
World War I methods
for code breaking to solve the
problem of how was the Enigma
machine set up this morning.
It would just take too
many people too long.
You need a mechanical
method to go
through at least a big
chunk of the permutations
and eliminate the impossible.
So again, if you've watched
"The Imitation Game,"
you will know-- because this
is now an established fact,
because that's what movies
like "The Imitation Game"
do for us-- they tell us what
the facts are-- you will know
that it is an established fact
that in the nick with five
seconds to go before
the D-day landings,
Alan Turing finally
soldered the last connection
on his bombe machine.
And lo and behold, the
bombe was able to spew out
decrypts of German
messages just in time
to save hundreds of British,
but unfortunately not
American lives because you guys
got to go on the wrong beach.
I'm sorry about that.
[LAUGHTER]
Actually some of that
might not be true.
In fact, that bit that
is particularly not true
is that it took the entire
war for this machine to work.
Alan Turing had
designed a bombe, which
is this thing you can
see on this slide,
to find at least
some candidates which
were potential plausible
settings of the way the Enigma
machine had been set
up, and he designed
methodology for program
that and discussed
with an engineer called Doc Keen
how that might be transformed
into a real device.
That had all been done by
Christmas 1939, at which point
the war in Europe had
involved the Russians
and the Germans
taking over Poland,
but otherwise
there wasn't really
a hot war going on at all in
Europe, and so by the time
the Germans invaded Norway
in April 1940 and France
in May 1940, they had actually
got a prototype machine
delivered at Bletchley
Park, and by the time
of the battle of Britain
in September 1940,
the bombe machine was already
producing intelligence,
intelligence that could be
used in the Battle of Britain
to help the Polish
and British air
forces defeat the Luftwaffe.
And so the first real
use of this intelligence
was actually really,
really in the war,
but that's very interesting,
but the point is, of course,
that Alan Turing had come up
with a design for a working
machine.
Now, his prototype was
improved by another Cambridge
mathematician called
Gordon Welchman,
but the fact is that
really astonishingly early
in the war-- and this is a
very interesting machine, this,
because it's actually
a digital machine.
It's producing a
yes or no answer.
It's not a universal machine,
because it's a single purpose
device.
It's designed to find
settings on Enigma machines,
but it's actually
quite interesting.
It's programmed.
It's programmed around the back.
There's a very complex
festoon of wires and stuff,
which enables it to
be set up to solve
a different problem every day
or for every Enigma network that
was in use, but this is a
step up from the Riemann zeta
function machine.
It's not an analog machine.
It is digital.
It's not electronic, and
it's programmable only
within a limited
purpose range, but it's
a big step on the road towards
universal computing machinery.
You may have come
across this thing.
This is Colossus.
This is the machine that
was used at Bletchley Park
to break a different
kind of German code,
the teleprinter code, which was
enciphered on a machine called
the Lorenz SZ42, and
the Colossus, again,
was another step forward on the
road towards modern computing
technology because this
is an electronic machine,
unlike the bombe, which
is electromechanical.
It's got moving parts in it.
This is an electronic
machine, and what's more,
the contents of one of the
messages they were testing
is actually programmed
into the machine
by flicking switches which
store the contents of a message
electronically using valves.
I'm sorry, in American, tubes.
That's right.
Yes, you call them tubes.
We call them valves,
but anyway these days we
call them transistors.
So the Colossus is a
very interesting-- now, I
can't claim that Alan
Turing designed Colossus.
This would be a complete
travesty, but what we do know
is that he was involved in
the team that was headed up
by none other than Max Newman,
that professor who started
Alan Turing off on
the computable numbers
work back in the '30s.
Max Newman was heading
up a machine group.
One of the responsibilities
of the machine group
was to develop
things like Colossus,
and Alan Turing was a
member of the machine group,
so he was essentially a
consultant to the project.
So he knew all about it, and
although he wasn't involved
in the design, it meant that he
was very well equipped in terms
of know how for the
big postwar projects,
both here in the United
States, but also in the UK.
There were going to be massive
computer building programs.
Everybody wanted
to try and bring
the whole concept of a multi
functional universal computing
machine to life, and the
reason they wanted to do this,
because this was basically John
von Neumann's project, which
was to try and find machines
that would solve much more
quickly the very, very
difficult equations that
needed to be processed
for doing things
like designing atom bombs.
And military needed
computing power,
and instead of hiring
roomfuls of people
with adding machines,
which is the way they'd
gone about in the
past, they thought
that actually having a
computing machine that
could be programmed
to do different kinds
of mathematical calculations
was a really good idea.
And the Brits had pretty
much the same thinking.
In fact, they this sort of
vision of a national computer
that people would be able to
send their problems off to,
and the national
computing service
would solve their
problems for them.
And would we need
one, or might we
need two computers to serve
the entire United Kingdom?
And that was the kind
of thinking at the time.
So Alan Turing was hired to
work on the UK's computing
project, which was funded
by the National Physical
laboratory in the UK,
and he was basically
hired as their chief
computer designer,
and he wrote a paper
heavily influenced
by John von
Neumann's work, which
was going to lead to the
creation of something
called the automatic
computing engine.
It's a nod back to the
Babbage calculators
of the 19th century.
This picture is of ACE
while it was being built.
That picture is
probably mid 1950s.
I would say about '55, '56.
The ACE, which Alan
Turing designed,
didn't actually complete
it's building process
until 1959, which was
12 years after he'd
completed his design.
Alan Turing did not kick
his heels for that 12 years.
In fact, he got so fed up that
within two years of completing
his design, he'd moved
on, and again, he'd
moved because he'd
been phoned up
by his old mate, Max
Newman, who was now
the professor of computing
at Manchester University.
Max Newman had asked
the UK government
if he could take away the
leftover bits of Colossus
at the end of the war, and
he filled a seven ton truck
with pieces of
Colossus and took him
to Manchester, where he built
something that "The London
Times" described as
the mechanical brain,
and rather better there's
another UK newspaper
described it as a
marvel of our time.
That's a picture of it
from "The London Times."
It's got wires all
hanging from the ceiling,
and it really does
look a bit of a mess.
I thought you might
like to hear a quote
from my book about this, and
I can do this shamelessly
because I'm not actually
quoting my own words here.
The Manchester
Computing Laboratory
is actually described by
Professor Williams, who
had invented the
memory device that
was being used in this machine.
And he describes the Royal
Society Computing Machine
Laboratory, which
sounds very grand.
So Professor Williams says
this, "a fine sounding phrase,
but what was the reality?
It was one room in a
Victorian building who's
architectural features are best
described as late lavatorial.
The walls were
brown glazed brick,
and the door was
labeled magnetism room.
And in fact, actually this
building is quite interesting,
because it's where Rutherford
had done his experiments
at the end of the 19th
century on splitting
the atom, and actually
the brown glazed brick--
it's still there,
and you're not really
allowed to go into the building
because it's a bit radioactive.
[LAUGHTER]
So it's an interesting
place, but they actually
were able to use this machine
to solve some real problems.
Now, this is quite
interesting, because they
had a memory of 1,024 bits.
So that's not really
a lot you can do.
It's not really a powerful
computing machine,
but they got this problem, which
again, Max Newman clever guy
that worked out that there's a
problem about Mersenne primes.
So again the mathematicians
around you will all be nodding.
2 to the power of n minus 1.
Are those numbers
prime or are they not?
Well, some of them
are, and some of them
aren't is the answer
to that question,
but Mersenne, who was a French
monk from the 16th century
had made a list
of these numbers,
where for the values
of n up to-- let
me check my notes-- 257.
And he said, these ones are
prime, and these ones are not,
but to do the sums
to actually work out
whether for n equals
2, 5, 7 requires
an awful lot of squared paper
and an awful lot of patience.
And so Max Newman thought, a-ha.
In binary, 2 to the n
minus 1 is 111111111.
So in other words, it's a great
problem for a computer that's
only got a memory of
1,024 bits, and so he
got the computer
working on this,
and they checked
Mersenne's work.
And this is all
very interesting,
because it all found
its way once again
into "The Times" newspaper.
So not only were they
running this splendid
rather grubby looking
photo, but they were also
running a nice little article
called "The Mechanical Brain."
There you are.
You can see from Saturday,
the 11th of June 1949.
"The Mechanical Brain, Answer
Found to 300 Year Old Sum."
So it goes on like this, but
the interesting thing about this
is it's not so much what it
says about the 300 year old sum,
it's actually what it
says about Alan Turing,
because they phoned him up.
And Newman was out
of the lab that day,
and so they got Alan Turing,
and what he said was this.
"This is only a foretaste
of what is to come
and only a shadow of
what is going to be.
We have to have some
experience with the machine
before we really know
its capabilities.
It may take years
before we settle down
to the new possibilities,
but I don't
see why it shouldn't enter
into one of the fields normally
covered by the human
intellect and eventually
compete on equal terms.
I don't think you can even draw
the line about writing sonnets.
The other comparison is
perhaps a little bit unfair
because a sonnet
written by a machine
will be better appreciated
by another machine."
[LAUGHTER]
All this about a computer that's
got a memory of 1,024 bits.
Oh dear, when you
can imagine that
in the rather staid
environment in the early 1950s,
or rather late 1940s
as we were, this
didn't go down
particularly well.
Max Newman's wife wrote a
letter to one of her friends
while this was going
on, and she said this.
Did you see the extraordinary
report in the times
two weeks ago on the
Manchester calculating machine
with the fantastic
remarks attributed
to Alan Turing and Max's
letter the following day
trying to clear things up?
"The Times" wired Alan,
who isn't on the telephone,
to ring up their office,
and they interviewed him
on the phone.
He's wildly innocent about
the ways of reporters,
and he has a bad stammer
when he's nervous or puzzled.
It was a great shock to
him when he saw "The Times"
and to Max who had been flying
back from Belfast that day.
We had a wretched weekend.
Starting at midnight
on the Friday night
when some sub editor of a local
paper ran up to get a story.
By Sunday, Max was
getting a bit gruff,
and when he said, what do
you want, to one newspaper,
the reporter replied only
to photograph your brain.
So we had some fun and games
at the end of the 1940s
with the Manchester
baby computer.
Actually, that was kind of
like a proof of concept,
and what they wanted
to do was to use
that to prove that
it was actually worth
spending some money on
a decent computer, which
was commercially
manufactured, and so this
is a photograph of it.
It was delivered to Manchester
University in, I think,
about 1951.
This was sometimes called
the Manchester Mark
1 or the Ferranti Mark 1.
It's, as you can see, a
rather more sort of swish
looking thing, and there's
a marketing photograph
of this elegant young woman
sitting in front of it
looking very professional.
You've also got an example of
what a computer program looks
like from the same period.
All these pound signs,
and forward slashes,
and half signs-- they're
programming basically
in the teleprinter code,
which is a nightmare.
And you can see Alan
Turing's handwritten comments
on the program with, how did
this happen, written across it.
Something has gone wrong
in this particular program.
It was not easy.
It was not easy, but actually I
think this is very interesting.
Here's a picture of him
with two of his colleagues.
He's the one standing
looking to the left.
He's standing by the Manchester
Mark 1, and what is he doing?
He's not actually
designing the machine
at this stage in the 1950s.
What he's doing is
designing the programs,
and he's designing the
programs to solve problems
that are of interest to him.
He's moved into a
completely different sphere.
What he's interested in
is developmental biology,
and he is modeling the
way that chemicals diffuse
through an embryo to see
if he can explain problems
in shape and form.
So to quote him again, "why
is a horse not a spherically
symmetrical object?"
There must be some variations
in concentration of chemicals,
whatever it is, that cause
the organism to develop
the way that it does.
So he's looking at plants.
He's looking at animals.
He's looking at things
like the patterns
that you see on the coats of
leopards, or friesian cows,
or whatever.
So he can explain some of
these using his differential
equations, and he's
using the computer
to essentially run contour
maps for him of the results
from these
differential equations.
So you can see that
he's taken-- this
is a piece of squared paper
that he has written out
the results that the computer
has given him, bearing
in mind that it probably came
out on a piece of punched tape,
so he's had to translate
it back into square paper.
There weren't graphical readouts
on computers in the 1950s.
So he's written the data in
these two digit hexadecimal
codes, and he's drawn
a contour map over it.
So when you've got
high values, he's
shaded it darker than where
he's got medium and low values,
and so you can see there's
a pattern emerging from that
which might or might not look
like a coat on an animal,
for example.
So that's what he's been doing.
So he's moved completely
now from a machine
as a theoretical thing for
solving a problem in pure maths
right through to using
a computer as a tool
to help him solve a problem in
biology much in the same way
that we would use
computers nowadays,
and all of that in the
course of about 15 years.
It's quite remarkable really.
As we all know, Alan
Turing died far too young,
but I thought you
might just like
the way that the UK tabloid
press reported his death.
Some of this-- it's sad,
but you just have to-- there
is some dark humor in here.
So we've go scientist robot
brain man is found dead,
and then you've got
a picture of him,
and then underneath
that you probably
can't read what it
says, but is says,
Dr. Turing, he fed the brain.
And mechanical brain
expert found dead.
Scientist [INAUDIBLE]
apparatus in room.
This is just classic the tabloid
reporting, and did own cooking.
I mean, what?
[LAUGHTER]
Anyway, so you
there is something.
I should think it was
probably pretty distressing
for the family to read all
this stuff at the time,
but 60 years on it's got
its entertainment value.
I'm done with the formal
speech part of this.
Thank you for
listening patiently.
I'm very happy to
take questions,
and then I think at some
stage I will be encouraged
to go outside, and if
people are interested,
I'm signing books, as well,
but anyway, let me stay here
and take questions
to begin with.
Now Rachel's coming
around with a mic.
AUDIENCE: Can you give
the history of your title?
SIR DERMOT TURING: I can.
It's got nothing to do
with Alan Turing, but OK.
In the middle part
of the 17th century,
King Charles I was
trying to raise
funds to establish a new
British colony on the Northeast
coast of the North
American continent.
In fact, what he
was trying to do
was found a colony called
New Scotland, or Nova Scotia.
And these kinds of
ventures cost money,
and the tax raising methods
of the time were rather poor.
As those of you who know your
English history will know,
this is what caused Charles I
to have his head chopped off--
was his inadequate
approach to taxation.
You talk to Americans
about British taxation.
This kind of
dangerous territory.
[LAUGHTER]
So we're talking about Canada
rather than the other 13
colonies, but so what happened
was that Charles I was selling
essentially titles.
He was selling peerages,
and in my case,
baronetcies, heritable titles
that you would contribute
so much money to the
Nova Scotia scheme,
and the you would get given
this stupid thing which
is sort of like a
piece of furniture
that you can pass
on to your children.
So that's where it comes from.
It's got nothing to
do with Alan Turing.
I've never been to Nova
Scotia, but never mind.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
just wanted to ask
is so obviously a number of
biographical works about Turing
have appeared over the
years, and I was just curious
if there were any
particular things you
felt that they had got wrong.
SIR DERMOT TURING: No, I don't
think that there's anything
that previous biographers
have particularly got wrong.
Andrew Hodges, whose biography
is probably the most well known
and probably the most
thorough in terms
of exhaustive
coverage of things--
he wrote that 30 years ago,
and actually that's a long time
ago in terms of knowing
new things about what
happened at Bletchley Park.
There's been lots of
revelations about Alan Turing's
wartime work in
particular, including
some new documents that
were released by the UK
equivalent of the NSA.
GCHQ released some
documents last year.
So it's not so much that
there's anything wrong.
It's just that there's
more detail available now,
and I also think I've
been slightly-- well,
so to make this
no sound like I'm
wanting to be negative
about other biographers,
because I don't think that
was ever part of my mission,
but I am slightly curious
and maybe not comfortable
in some senses with the way
that Alan Turing comes across.
We all get our
mental picture of him
from watching stuff in
the media, don't we?
Benedict Cumberbatch's
performance in "The Imitation
Game" is great.
I mean, it's a great movie, but
that's kind of the Alan Turing
that we carry around
with each other.
Is that true?
And there's been a number of
what turned out in some cases
to be myths when I looked
into them about his childhood,
and his upbringing, and
how he got on with his work
colleagues, and so forth.
I it feel to some extent
that there's a need to,
first of all,
investigate that and see
whether those myths turned
to have any substance,
and on the whole, they turn
out to be over dramatizations.
And I think Alan Turing would've
fit in quite happily here
working with you
guys, and you probably
thought he was no different
from half your other work
colleagues.
He wasn't that weird, you know?
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, at least
that's the impression
you get from talking
to the people who
worked with him at
Bletchley Park, people who
worked with him in Manchester.
Yeah, you wouldn't necessarily
have wanted to have him
at your sherry party.
Indeed, my father did want
him at his sherry party.
Badly dressed.
Rude to the other guests.
Fish out of water.
Very uncomfortable in that
kind of social setting.
Would've thought working
would've been absolutely great,
because you're talking about--
[LAUGHTER]
None of you have ever been to
a sherry party in your lives,
and what's more, you'd all
be talking about the stuff
that you all enjoyed
talking about together,
so it's you just put people
in the right environment.
So I think there's been
a tendency, if you like,
for the actors who are
portraying him to make him out
as being this sort
asocial genius,
when actually he might have been
a bit more normal, a bit more
approachable.
Yeah, a clever guy, but you all
work with really clever people,
so that doesn't mean that it's
sort of like he's unattainably
distant, his cleverness.
I think it's more in some senses
to try and normalize things.
I wouldn't want to say that
any of the other biographers
were guilty of the
hype themselves.
There's some nuances that I
wouldn't perhaps go along with,
but I think it's just
a matter of bringing
the story up to date and perhaps
normalizing a bit against some
of the dramatizations that
we'll have seen and built up
our own picture of.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'd like to
ask you a little bit more
about what you were just
talking about with some
of the recent information that's
been coming out about Colossus.
I listen to the
Bletchley Park podcast,
and they were talking
about that, too,
and they were saying
that, as much as we now
know about Enigma,
we might come to know
about Colossus, much
of which was still
classified until recently.
And they never really
talked, though.
What do you know about what
Turing's role was on Colossus?
I know Newman was the head.
What role did Turing play in it?
Do we know?
SIR DERMOT TURING: Well,
more than what I've already
said to you this afternoon.
I think it's probably
not right to imagine
that Alan Turing was very
closely involved in Colossus.
What I can tell you is
that he was certainly
being one of the top
code breaking team
at Bletchley Park.
When they found the
teleprinter code problem, which
sort of surfaced
early in the war,
they certainly gave it to him,
and indeed, a bunch of others,
to work on, and so he
was certainly responsible
for some of the methodologies
they were using to try
and break into these codes.
So there's a technique
called Turingismus,
for example, which I'm not
going to try and explain to you,
but it involves basically
adding together two messages
to try and find out where the
settings on the wheels were,
and you're basically
doing binary addition
and seeing some
patterns coming out
of that tells you
something about the way
that the machine was set up.
So we know we know that he was
involved in the teleprinter
code project, but also
I think the real work
on developing
Colossus as a machine
to solve the problems
was basically
the brainchild of other
people, because by that stage,
Alan Turing moved on
to different role.
So by 1942, he's moving across
from being a code breaker
essentially to being-- I
wouldn't say in charge of,
but to have a role within
essentially a security
organization that's
looking at the security
of Allied communication.
So he's spending time
over here in the US.
He's looking at things
like the machinery that's
being used to encrypt
voice communications.
So a classic example of this
is Roosevelt and Churchill
having conversations
over the radio telephone.
The Germans were listening to
those for the first three years
of the war.
So Alan Turing
sent over to the US
to check out the security
of the device that
had been invented here
at Bell Labs in New York
to encrypt those communications.
He's also checking
out the effectiveness
of written
communication security
so that basically the Allies
own teleprinter encryption
techniques.
So he's kind of moved across
from being a code breaker
into being more of
a security person,
but I think the idea of
Newman's machine group
is actually quite good,
because that encompasses
both sides of that
divide, but it just
means that his role
has changed a bit,
and he's moved away from the
front line of code breaking,
which means that the
Colossus project,
while he was aware of it,
and as I say, basically
acting as consultant to it,
it's not really his project.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SIR DERMOT TURING:
For a long time,
people wanted it to
be, because you've
got Alan Turing, the
father of the computer,
the author of the
computer [INAUDIBLE],
the great Bletchley
Park code breaker.
Of course, Colossus
had to-- but that was
like a guess in the absence
of decent quality information,
and I think nowadays
there's enough known
to be sure that that's
not really his main thing.
He knew all about, but he
wasn't really doing it.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
if you can talk
a little bit about the
story of writing this book.
What inspired it?
How much of it was internal
knowledge in the family?
How long it took
you to right it?
What were the hard parts?
Et cetera.
SIR DERMOT TURING: Thank
you for the question.
In fact, there were about
five questions in there,
weren't there?
[LAUGHTER]
I think you've probably
got the flavor already
of some of the things that
were slightly nagging at me
before I started work on it
and whether I could investigate
these myths, if you
like, to find out
whether they were myths and
also to bring the story up
to date a bit.
I also felt that for a non
mathematical reader, a non
specialist reader, somebody who
isn't prepared to say, right,
I am now tacked up with
enough Starbucks coffee
that I can tackle chapter
three and this business
about computable numbers.
Not everybody has got
the intellectual courage
to take that journey.
So I thought that there might
be something that I, as a non
mathematician, could
bring to a wider audience
without hopefully
getting bogged too much
and that kind of stuff.
So that was part of it.
And then you asked
how long did it take
and what were the hard parts.
And the really
interesting thing about it
was that it didn't take
anything like as long
as I thought it was going to,
because the hard parts-- well,
apart from things like
computable numbers, which
I recognized were
out of my depth,
so I wasn't even going to
try and swim in those waters,
but the really interesting
thing is how easy it all
was, how easy it
was because people
make stuff available to you
actually going and talking
to people.
It was really interesting.
People opened our doors.
They said, have you
thought about this?
And did you know
about so and so?
And actually suddenly you
find that loads of people
were really, really
interested in the project
and wanted to help with it.
And so I have to say it's been
a really, truly good experience.
It's been very, very good.
Is that the positive
note to finish on?
I don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Thank you very much
SIR DERMOT TURING: All
right, sounds like it is.
[APPLAUSE]